it's very easy to
say women are [ __ ] they're difficult
right as much as it's like oh hashtag me
too
and whatever girl you and i have lived
that life oh my god and it's like oh
she's so difficult she's such a [ __ ]
and
you know whereas men are assertive and
strong and you know very businessman yes
yes leaders
oh
and there was so many times that i held
back for fear
of that label which i got anyway oh yeah
and every time i was like oh do i really
want to start a thing about this
do i really want to be difficult
what happened is that my concerns about
the project
came true
the tv show didn't work or the book
didn't work or whatever it was didn't
work and then nobody wants to work with
you again anyway because nobody like
success has many fathers but failure is
an orphan it's like you know work with
you anyway so if you just trusted your
gut
it would have worked and they would have
had to continue working with you even
though they would have called you a
[ __ ] they would have called you
difficult
so that kind of self-doubt in those
moments i think i've paid for dearly
really do you think i paid for dearly
um
and when it comes to
physicality and overall health
oh my god i
made i have made mistakes that i never
thought that i would make and one was
being overly confident with with my
fitness and thinking like well i can do
that like this and it's you know crazy
[ __ ] like racing horses you know however
fast across an open plane and
you know jumping jet skis over you know
six foot swells and and i got away with
all of it until one day i didn't
and one day i took a really bad ball and
fractured my um my l3
and subsequently herniated three discs
let me tell you
i never understood the meaning of pain
until that happened and now i have a
very healthy respect
what happened
what did you do
oh just you know when you get caught up
in like the instagram [ __ ] of like oh
for shits and giggles it serves no
purpose and
you made a mistake slipped and fell
and all those years of like being so
careful and eating all the right foods
and you know building my core strength
and balancing my biomechanics
like it is second
[ __ ] it all up [ __ ] it all up
another one divorcing your body bye
bye
you can come back to me in like two
months oh my god how long were you out
oh three months couldn't walk couldn't
stand had to crawl on the floor did you
just now
no uh
not
yes
and i say not yet because
it feels in my mind it's kind of like
having a time bomb in the base of my
spine
um
because i'm like well what happens if
one day i make a wrong move or i do the
wrong thing
and
that's it you know you kind of only get
one so i i was working um
with a doctor named dr stuart mcgill and
he's a phd he's a scientist and this is
his specialties studying the spine
um he's kind of like this crazy savant
genius
and uh you know he got me through all
the phases of it
but i'll never forget you know i was
feeling really confident i was pain-free
and i was like i'm jumping rope and i
did this and i did this and he goes
listen
you will never
have your old back
back
chill the [ __ ] out and i was like wow i
mean i it hit me like a ton of bricks
you give it a meaning
and you learn from it and you grow and
you become wiser but at the end of the
day sometimes
you make a mistake
and it's like you got hit by a bus
you're
you're living without that leg for the
rest of your life you know what i mean
you you make you make a mistake
and you'll never get to that next level
of success
sorry to be a downer it's really more
just like a warning
be wise be smart and the younger you
take that advice
the better off you're gonna be but so
often we don't pay attention to it until
it's all falling apart
you know what you know what i mean like
you don't read the book about anti-aging
until you're
old [ __ ]
[Music]
yes so right if anything i would say
like
20 year olds 30 year olds like pay
attention pay attention now
now is where it really matters in so
many ways was there a lesson because i
feel like i've in my life like the
really shitty things that have happened
i'm able to extract a really big lesson
in it or i'm able to develop empathy
for
in a way that i never had it before
because i might use i might used to
think in this way like if i'm putting
myself in your position before an injury
like it's not that big of a deal you'll
be fine like make sure you do this and
like you don't have empathy for someone
who's going i'm injured you know i might
have said before like are you really
that injured like can you not do
something come on get out of bed what do
you mean you can't walk oh please i know
dude right so was there some like gem
that did you do you feel like your
empathy for
someone with an injury changed
afterwards or was there a big life
lesson from being on the dl for three
months
you know with the
with the physical injury yes i got all
of the above a completely different
understanding of
people who live with pain because
everybody had a horror story for me it
was like
this kid this 30-something-year-old kid
delivered a bed because we moved to
miami and i'm laying on my stomach
because i can't stand up and he's like
you hurt your back didn't you and i was
like yeah how do you know and he's like
i did the same thing and he had like
told me this horror story he's like i
live with pain but i manage it 30 years
old
and everybody everybody i live with pain
i live with pain i live with pain and
ask jesus so
i do think
it has yet to reveal itself to me how
because i don't really want to make
money off of it it's like it's not
really can't really be a book it can't
really be anything that i profit off of
but i wonder down the road am i going to
do something that helps people in
chronic pain that don't know which way
to turn that don't have the right
doctors that don't know how to feel
better
um
i i have you're right a different
understanding a much greater empathy
because before it was like oh that sucks
you know why don't you try swimming
right exactly do something right
so maybe it's not
maybe it's a character maybe it's like
maybe it's just an empathy and
a personality thing like you know
there's stuff that i used to judge
pretty hardcore and now i look at it
look at some things now that i've had to
experience that i'm like oh i get it
kind of like i'm so sorry i judged
before
i know right you learn things
there's a major lesson to every one of
these things
but you know i was just talking to my
shrink about this the other day i was
like look man if i got hit by a bus
tomorrow
and i was in a wheelchair i would
definitely go the whole like how do i
inspire people how do i live my best
life i would make that i would do my
best to make those lemons into lemonade
however
deep down i would still be like [ __ ] i'm
never
never gonna walk again i'm never gonna
run again i'm never gonna ski again
and
while i would say listen
just like you right like let's make the
lemonade out of lemons what can we gain
how can we come deeper why is there more
intelligent and all of the above
if you can avoid getting hit by that bus
and there's work you can do
to prevent these mistakes or it's like
look dumb people never learn right smart
people learn from their own mistakes but
wise people learn from other people's
mistakes
if there's anybody wise out there
take your life lessons in other ways but
you are right there are certain things i
had to learn the hard way
and i was that was absolutely one of
them without fail without question
you're right in business um in that
bucket of just kind of
being
yourself essentially and and it's not
even just like a matter of like
flexing a muscle that you have to be
tough
and be in charge it's more i mean i feel
like there's an essence of like just
like knowing intuitively what's right
and wrong and
speaking up for that so
what changed like is there an example of
something where you're like i stuck to
my guns and this happened and this is an
example of i didn't stick to my guns and
this happened
um here's a perfect example it was like
how did we get
jillian off of the biggest loser onto a
jillian platform that's about jillian
and this is i say how do we like my
business partner myself the people
involved in trying to grow
the brand that was my brand and not the
biggest loser brand
so one example would be um the spin-off
show called losing it with jillian right
and
um the head of the network
wanted it quick wanted it now wanted it
fast and gave us six weeks it was like
okay jillian's gonna move in with these
families we're gonna come back in six
weeks and you know
there's the reveal
you know he was in charge and so i was
like this isn't going to work man like
this isn't gonna like you're gonna go on
this kind of like intense journey where
this person lost a baby and this person
went through like all these things that
caused people to utilize food as a
coping mechanism and
you need to move the bus when we move
the bus that's the biggest loser like
the bus has to move it's got to be like
look at that amazing transformation
nobody can do that in six weeks i can
come back in six weeks they can be 50
pounds later and they look like they got
a haircut maybe
the payoff's not there right and he
didn't want to hear it and he called my
business partner john carlo who you've
met you tell that [ __ ]
to shut the [ __ ] up or we're gonna
rethink our entire
relationship with her
and i got scared and i was like
uh oh i better and of course guess what
the show didn't work
and then jillian michaels can't carry
her own vehicle
and then it was a disaster from that
point on whereas maybe when i was riding
high on the number one show on nbc
and arguably one of the bigger draws on
that show
um and had the highest q score at the
time right
and
had i maybe said you know what then i'm
not doing it
instead of having the failure under my
belt
that that created a stigma that nobody
wanted to touch right it's like well she
can't carry it she couldn't pull it off
she couldn't do it
had i just said no
instead of allowing the fear to be like
okay well let me be the good girl you
know i may not get this opportunity
again like let me do it
such a big mistake mama such a big
mistake
[Music]